i want to move over to just like
the very end here so
i guess can you tell me a little bit
about what what's going through emily's
head at the end of the show because
the whole thing is such an extreme
emotional roller coaster and
you know when she takes the stand at the
end you're given the impression that
she's in a very
level-headed space but then at the very
end when another baby enters the
situation she still goes back to birdie
mckeegan
so does she think the baby's hers
or is it more of a draw to you know like
filling that hole in her heart again
i think it's both i think it's both like
everything we've been talking about and
is why i feel so lucky to have gone to
play this character because
she's so inherently human and it's so
devastating to like imagine that someone
sh she can't survive
she won't be able to survive her her
heart was taken from her
her whole reason for living and i think
she wants to believe that she can
continue
but when given this other opportunity to
survive
she takes it and she's like if i'm going
to take this opportunity i'm going to
need to
to be in it wholeheartedly so
it's it's complicated it's the type of
complication that goes right back to
what we were saying before
it's like i will never forget emily's
journey in season one of
perry mason because i can't quite put a
finger on exactly how she's feeling at
any given moment and it just so
well reflects the complications of
being a human being and having your own
feelings and being influenced by those
around you so
i don't know the fact that you don't
have like a very specific like black and
white answer to this i i think speaks to
the power of the show and the
performance
thank you so much i mean i i feel
very lucky to have been given this
opportunity like
to play this woman